un peu plus de dix mille c'est le nombre
de militants ump yves binois appelés aux
urnes ce dimanche pour élire le
président de leur mouvement
qui est concerné les adhérents à jour de
leur cotisation et dont la dernière
cotisation remonte à 2011
en conséquence ceux qui ne sont plus
adhérent depuis 2011 ne pourront pas
voter
treize bureaux de vote sont répartis
dans le département pour les
circonscriptions qui nous concerne c'est
un versailles art concours a plaisir à
elancourt ou encore à rambouillet que
les militants doivent se rendre muni
d'une simple carte d'identité
les listes ont été validées par une
commission nationale
les bureaux de vote seront ouverts de 9
heures à 18 heures comme lors d'un
scrutin électoral classique il y aura un
président de bureau un suppléant et deux
assesseurs représentant chacun des
candidats à la fin du vote les bulletins
seront dépouillés sur place et les
résultats communiqué la fédération
départementale de l'ump à versailles
difficile de savoir combien de militants
vont participer au vote
jean françois raynal le secrétaire
départemental adjoint de l'ump table sur
au moins 50% de participation en dessous
de ce chiffre
il sera dit il déçu